السلام عليكم ورحمه الله هذا موجز الاخبار
من الجزيره تعرضت العاصمه الروسيه موسكو
والعاصمه الاوكرانيه
لهجمات متبادله بالطائرات المسيره وقالت
وزاره الدفاع روسيا الهجوم الاوكرانيه
الذي وصفته بالارهابي تم بثمان طائرات
مسيره وانه تم اسقاطها كلها من جهه اخرى
قال عمده موسكو ان الهجوم اسفر عن اصابه
شخصين بجروح طفيفه
وقال الرئيس الروسي وفلاديمير بوتين ان
هجمات المسيرات الاوكرانيه على موسكو جاءت
ردا على ضربه روسيه استهدفت مركز القياده
الاستخبارات العسكريه الاوكرانيه ووصفه
بمحاوله استدراج لبلاده
قالت عن مستشارين رئاسي اوكراني رفيع
ودبلوماسيين اوروبيين اوكرانيا وحلفاء
يخططون لعقد قمه لزعماء العالم من شانها
استبعاد روسيا بهدف حشد الدعم لشروطي
لانهاء الحرب بحسب الصحيفه فان هناك
مساعيه
معاده صياغه خطه سلام الاوكرانيه من عشر
نقاط بطرق تجعلها اكثر قبولا للقوى
العالميه الاخرى كالهندي والبرازيل
والسعوديه والصين
اكد الفزارات الخارجيه الفلسطينيه انها
تنظر بخطوره بالغه لاقدام عناصر استيطانيه
مسلحه على نصب خيام تمهيدا لاقامه بؤره
استيطانيه جديده على اراضي بلده دراسيا في
قضاء محافظه نابلس واعتبرت الوزاره في
بياننا هذه الخطوه هي ترجمه رسميه لسياسه
الحكومه الاسرائيليه
وقد اعاد مستوطنون متطرفون انشاء مدرسه
دينيه في بؤره حومش الاسطانيه على اراضي
قريه برقه شمال غربيه مدينه نابلس بالضفه
الغربيه وعقلت مصادر فلسطينيه ان مجموعه
من المستوطنين اقامت كرفانا في مساحه
جديده داخل المستوطنه المخلاه منذ عام
بتصديق وزيري الدفاع والماليه
وحضر تقرير سري للاتحاد الاوروبي بما وصفه
بالتسرع الكبير للضغط الاسرائيلي على
القدس ومحاوله تغيير الواقع الديموغرافي
فيها واشارت تقرير الذي حصلت صحيفه
الاسبانيه على نسخه منه الى انه يتعين على
بروكسيل ودول الاتحاد الاوروبي ان تعارض
بشكل لا لبسه فيه الخطط احاديه الجانب
الهادفه لتغيير وضع وحدود القدس
الجزيره ان منطقه الشريعه الغابه في
الخرطوم شهدت اطلاق نار بانواع مختلفه
للاسلحه وذلك غدا تمديد هدنه وقف اطلاق
النار لخمسه ايام وافادت مصادر وسودانيه
للجزيره بوقوع اشتباكات وسطه وشماليه
الخرطوم واطلاق نار كثيف جنوب شرقي مدينه
الاوبيض بولايه شمال كردفان
قال قائد الجيش السوداني ورئيس مجلس
السياده عبد الفتاح البرهان ان القوات
المسلحه لم تستخدم ووصفه بالقوه المبيته
وانها ستضطر الى ذلك اذا لم ينفع العدو
لصوت العقل بحسب قوله
اكد مصدر نيراني مطلع للجزيره التواصل الى
تسويه مع الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه
بشان موقع يشتبه في احتوائه على جزيئات من
اليورانيوم المخصب وقال وزير الخارجيه
الايرانيين التواصل مع الاوروبيين بشان
مفاوضات الملف النووي مستمر ونتبادل
الرسائل مع واشنطن يتم عبر مصطفى اقليميين
وعقل المدير العام للوكاله الدوليه لطاقه
الذريه رافايل هناك عددا من القضايا التي
تعمل الوكاله عليها مع ايران ويتم احراز
بعض التقدم في بعض منها
انتهى الموجه زي ما كنتم طبت اوقاتكم بكل
خير